but you know you've a bit mugged no yeah
but uh one time right we uh me and some
friends I I drove my car to Manhattan to
meet up with some other comics alright
and uh so I go meet them and we do a
show so now I'm gonna give everybody a
ride back in my car
uh-huh let me get to my car there's
somebody sitting in the car really yeah
see how I just left there right that's
funny so you know in your mind does
crazy things like when they held you
down on the ground what was flashing
through your mind so many things
flashing my mind in like one instant it
was crazy
you don't know I've been in situations
like that before in terms of like like a
[ __ ] up situation and you literally go
I can't believe this is happening
surreal it's surreal yeah yeah cuz my
dread one's flow into your body
yeah cuz I have a friend named Roger and
all do and I was like oh we all have
arrived oh that's Roger sitting in the
car he just met me there and it's
probably him in the car but I'm like
then I'm like how to [ __ ] with Roger
know where you parked yeah and why Roger
be in your how did he get in your home
yeah my mind tried to smooth the whole
[ __ ] out immediately and like and then I
notice a stranger in your car holy [ __ ]
sitting there's three of us you didn't
lock it it was locked there's three of
us and we rolled up on the dude yeah and
then talent he's tall as [ __ ] that's his
name yeah his name is talent yeah it's a
common from New York and uh you know he
rolls up rose he goes like with like now
we surround the car and then talents
like hey man wine down the window so he
does this like one wine yeah yeah like
like like it was an old car you had the
dual wind
I mean Sunny's like it can I help you
like it's his car amazing he's not crazy
he's just court
so then tell us like what are you doing
in the car I didn't take nothing
so towns like wine the window all the
way down so he
he does and in town just punches him and
disorientate him so that he can't do
anything and then we open the door and
we take him out and then we beat him up
a little bit
did you really yeah you kicked him well
I held him it was like it was like the
movies like one guy holds one arm yeah
everybody and then we took his [ __ ] set
of keys that could open any car door and
and I took those yes like a bunch of GM
keys and just keys that can open
anything cuz he didn't break my door
that's the first time my car but got
broken into and the door handle wasn't
ripped afterwards so you just he just
walked into that Wow
and we just took his keys so I can call
the cops
nah all right we don't sneak street
justice yeah yeah who was he gonna
complain to that's some lady go into
your car while you were inside it yeah
two weeks ago I was out route no routes
right ed mm-hmm in the parking lot and
then I'm just put the put the you know
start the car mm-hmm and I in my
peripheral I know there's someone else
in the car and they look over and
there's like a white homeless lady and
she goes yeah well I like says something
crazy like doesn't speak English yeah
that's how I did it and then she circled
my I get out I get out oh and she left
and she's just walked on this how'd you
get in your car well I was just like
sitting there I think I was playing like
um SimCity like in the car I was in the
yeah city it's play some city uh-huh and
I heard the door open and then I look
over and then she was there Oh homeless
I don't know her [ __ ] living
circumstances [ __ ] Dilbert alright
you dick sucking Philip
[Music]